hi silver tits guys again and I want to
start this tutorial right off the bat
with some explanation about terraforming
right so there's actually a few ways you
can go about doing terraforming of a
coaster but one way I actually really
like doing a lot over the very common
way of doing it is something that I have
no name yet and I don't know if there's
actually someone who came up with the
name for this method but the way it
works is first you come up with the
shape for your hill or whatever it is
that you're terraforming and then after
you've done that you're going to smooth
it so it's kind of like this but then of
course it's going to be more precise
since you're going to work with larger
shapes now the reason why I actually
like doing this a lot is because the
other method that you can use is their
creator here or a create mountain or a
creates whatever you're creating method
via the creating hill thing inside
roller-coaster country but the problem
you get here is that you're very prone
to getting these very pointy kind of
heroes like these and especially with
the mountain making thing where you
really get these things that you can
stab someone with to death and I don't
really like seeing these and it's Lee
one of the big newbie mistakes that
people often make that they use this way
of making mountains and it's not really
the best way to go around doing it
especially when you want to have paths
on top of those mountains and that's why
today I'm going to add some little
terraforming around this little area
with the corkscrews and later on I'm
going to place a path on that so I want
to start off by just raising the grounds
about 4-h right here and as you can see
this is going to be a bit messy with the
corkscrews but we can fix this later on
by using the smoothing tool and I want
to have a path to run these chords and
run the curve right here so I'm going to
race the grounds
that should be about enough I don't want
to raise it a lot more excitement when I
have too many stairs going on this
should be about good for now and the
entire idea here is that it's going to
be a bit of a foresty area at least
that's what I want to go for a bit of a
forest the area with path work around
the right right here and some semi
tunnel sections right here with walls on
the sides of these trucks and the first
thing that I'm going to have to do is
smoothing so I'm going to smooth it
right here because that what I want to
have is I'm going to have the exit path
right here so I'm going to have to go
underneath this piece of track so I can
add for example a staircase over here
and that means I will I will have to
smooth this area before it's going to
look too square and man-made right so
now this actually already looks a lot
better than what we just had because
it's of course a lot less blocky but we
still got some problems in here which is
not very good and what we're going to do
over here is actually not what you might
expect I'm going to lower the ground
instead of actually raising it so that
it all fits and I'm going to do that
over here as well though mmm let's not
do that yeah I actually need to smooth
it a bit more so never mind that I need
to smooth it just a bit more and make it
a bit more hilly again and then smooth
it again in order that it's going to be
the way I want it to it still needs to
be a bit more smooth when it comes to
smoothing a rollercoaster 3 and I really
can't stress this tip enough you should
really smooth as much as you like
there's no such thing as too much
smoothing unless it really affects the
shape of your mountain but you really
need to make sure that you smooth things
up because all
little sharp ends that you get see they
are not realistic and you don't really
want to have them in your scenery right
so with that out of the way yeah I think
that's that's about good enough so again
I'm going to lower the ground right here
and over here as well and I'm going to
do that for every spot just so that the
track is just touching the ground but
that's not really a big issue right here
right so I just keep doing that for
every one of them and the plan I've got
right here is I'm saying right here
waiting many times why do I do that but
anyway the plan here is just to add some
walls on the sides of these things which
is something you commonly see with PNM's
especially if they've got some terrain
interaction going on like there is over
here terrain interaction is always a
good thing even if you've got a simple
bnm sit down going like this one terrain
interaction is never a bad idea just
won't stress that as well right so it
seems like I can't really make that
higher so I'll just have to do this
now that looks pretty good except I
don't want that to be like that now if
you've got some problems with
terraforming like over here this area is
all squarey because there's this large
curve right here you're just going to
have to remove that curve then take the
smoothing tool and smooth it up and then
it should be fine
which is something really stupid but
yeah you can't do anything about it so
you'll just have to deal with it but
when you remove the track you can
terraform so if you've got some things
that don't look very smooth I always
recommend you to remove the track smooth
it out like so Oh
though that's a bit too much moving
right there I didn't want to smooth that
and this is going to be a bit of an
issue because I can't raise it so I'll
have to remove this track as well right
and now I can actually smooth it okay
that's a lot better and then I can build
it again and then it should look good so
yeah I kind of like that it's just some
very small minor terrain interaction
going on but just because I wanted to
have this bath go around here I still
have some way of not having this big
valley in which the coaster would run
but also I have some small terrain
interaction going on so that I can
actually add some little walls just to
yeah make the entire area looking bit
less boring I can now see though that I
still have this blocky area going on so
I have to remove the track right here
smooth it out of bits I have to remove
this trick as well okay then smooth it
up and then we're good to go and I guess
I might as well at these walls already
and explain to you why I just like that
why I just like these things so kind of
like the thing the the wall thingy that
Kumba has things yeah it's it's got
khumba to benumb sit now and I know that
for as a faz yeah well anyway I think
yeah I'm kind of addressing here I you
need to get some some walls from mobis
once the set called mobis curved walls
those those are the best walls for this
kind of situation and they they have the
best exterior and they also have pieces
that fits almost every single wall
situation you can get but right now all
I need is the straight conforming walls
and I'm I think I'm going to make these
the this color right now even though I
don't really have a theme yet it's just
a very neutral color that which is what
I would always yeah and also I would
always recommend you to use either great
or like great great gray or light brown
or dark brown perhaps but nothing too
fancy no very vibrant colors or anything
unless you are making something really
stupid or
weird right mmm that still needs
smoothing oh well I'll do that later on
but I hope you can actually see the idea
right here that I have and you can keep
this area underneath here as grass but
you can also just add some little
pavement thingies all depends on what
you want
I might actually add a pavement later on
but this is actually one of the one of
my favorites terrain interaction tricks
just a small wall along the sides of the
coaster you can also you can also use
this for tunnels underneath paths and
basically anything I might actually add
that somewhere along the track as well
but I'm not entirely sure about that
right so now about smoothing this little
part right here because it's not looking
very very nice that's a bit better but
this little area doesn't really seem to
want to conform oh well I'm just going
to have to race everything around it
then right so now it's all good yup
perfect so that's it for the
terraforming that's actually all for now
but I'm going to add some terraforming
in a different area as well
I think at least I think so I might
actually add it in here as well just
make it a recurring theme along the
coaster you don't have to do this but I
just feel like doing this right now
oops I'm lowering it mmm isn't it a bit
too high by the way also when it comes
to making these things I always
recommend you to use even numbers for
the height of your hills just so you can
add staircases because most staircases
go up about 2h plus I don't know why but
in I just notice that somehow it looks
bit better when you've got even numbers
going on when it comes to terraforming
right so now this looks like this may
look a bit weird but when you smooth it
things are probably going to be about
two times as low as they were before so
that's something you have to think about
when you're doing these kinds of things
also this is not looking really great so
I think I'm going to remove that looping
because it's ruining everything and as
soon as you have removed that you can
smooth this area outs no problems and
then you can add a looping again and it
should be fine although right now it's
not really working well that's that's a
bummer I smooth it I guess I shouldn't
move that that much it's still a bit too
much what eventually it always works in
the end because every time that you
smooth it too much and you build again
then you're going to lower it again
until you get to this point where it's
nearly perfect but I think yeah I just
killed it in the end so that's not
really nice I have to smooth that a bit
but then it should be good right
mm well that's a bit hard I'm still
ruining it every time it's not really
good it usually works out a bit better
than right now I don't know what's going
on right so we got it in the end so
that's nice and now I want to create
some little whatever you call those
things I really have no name for this
thing that's all
if anybody knows a name because there
may be a name because it's actually a
real technique they use for real
coasters well that'd be awesome if you
could post in the comments but I doubt
that it's actually having a name right
so you just want to have it go around
the coaster but just not touching the
track right so that's all looking good
mmm though I'm not really too sure about
this it's good in now it's not good
enough now I'm going to have to remove
this looping because I want it to be a
bit more smooth then smooth it out over
here yet
right that should be good and have Luke
perfect now I could just smooth out this
area around it a bit more but other than
that it's pretty much it's pretty much
done and of course this is not really
good terraforming but this is just the
terraforming around the coaster like
that's another tip I want to give you
before you go to the real terraforming
like any mountains everywhere and that
kind of stuff I recommend you to do the
terraforming around your coaster first
because your coaster always messes with
where you can build mountains and it's
always a pain in the bum let's say bomb
well let's not be too well yeah never
mind but yeah I just recommend doing
that because otherwise you're going to
try to make mountains but they'll be
ruined by your coaster track because the
terraforming module and rock screen 3 is
very annoying but I think that's about
it I mean this won't be too much of a
problem so thanks for watching this
short tutorial and just some
terraforming tricks I'll add some walls
do this later on just like it it over
there and in the next episode I don't
know what I'm going to do but I think I
think I'm going to start on the station
so till then